[Music]
[Applause]
since 2000 the following players have
had at least 92 passing touchdowns and
56 or fewer interceptions in their first
four seasons so those are the numbers
that baker mayfield has first four years
92 touchdowns 56 interceptions
other players who have
numbers in that grouping patrick mahomes
russell wilson desean watson derek carr
josh allen andrew luck carson wentz dak
prescott matt ryan and baker mayfield
so that would be considered a pretty
good start
not a great start but a pretty good
start now i factor in four head coaches
four offensive coordinators and
you know maybe you you have a sliding
scale there of exactly what you got from
baker mayfield
now you also have the health factor in
there with him playing through injury
maybe he's healthy ready to go and this
is a
it felt like it was a move that was
rumored for quite some time because we
kept thinking he's got to end up
somewhere is it seattle
maybe pittsburgh was it going to be
carolina and then finally the panthers
pulled the trigger on this joe person he
covers the carolina panthers he's the
beat writer for the athletic kind enough
to join us on this topic on short notice
how's the move been received there in
carolina joe
i think folks are mostly pretty excited
about it they
panthers fans have seen
kind of a revolving door at quarterbacks
since
really since ron rivera left and matt
rule came in they made the decision of
course to cut ties with with cam newton
they did bring him back briefly last
year uh after sam darnold got hurt but
then it was teddy bridgewater then it
was darnold who i just mentioned
and uh
it just
it hadn't worked i mean they have they
have for one reason or another none of
those guys were helped by the fact
that christian mccaffrey's been injured
the last two years obviously but
they uh
they're going to keep swinging at the
quarterback position obviously they
obvious they drafted matt corral in the
third round this year
viewed him dan as more of a
developmental quarterback that the plan
was never to rush him along so
what you said is absolutely right this
felt like
it was going to be inevitable
uh beginning really on the second night
of the draft when when cleveland and the
panthers were talking and it continued
up through mini camp and now finally the
panthers sort of put a fourth of july
july 5th actually deadline on it
try to get it done and they did
i'm just trying to figure out the
strategy here because you keep you know
you said they keep swinging you know
trying to get a quarterback here at some
point i got to blame the people trying
to get the quarterback that they keep
missing on this i like matt corral a lot
he kind of reminds me of a more athletic
baker mayfield and he's a third round
pick so he's not expensive and if baker
does well you're gonna have to pay him
market value
um
sam darnold
uh is it a truly an open competition in
your your opinion that it's between
those two to be the starting quarterback
not really i mean they they went and got
they went and got baker because they
didn't feel confident in sam darnold i
mean obviously they they tried to get to
sean watson you just mentioned corral
and
that they're
if maybe it's open for the first week or
so at training camp only because baker
only because baker is going to have to
cram the playbook uh and you know learn
this ben mcadoo offense in a pretty
short period of time
um camp starts for the panthers two
weeks from today
um but
yeah i mean and your point about about
matt rule and and david tepper the owner
and the general manager scott fitter is
absolutely valid i mean that this team
has has
the decision makers have have missed at
the most important position
on the field and if they they miss again
and it probably going to cost matt rule
his job and could could mean scott
fitter who did arrive a year after rule
he could be in trouble too
how did baker do with the media
yesterday
it was interesting i thought we were
going to have all kinds of
fireworks and
some some
some pretty juicy uh quotes about
cleveland and getting disrespected
and it was very clear even the way i
mean he was in a button-down shirt from
what looked like his kitchen or dining
room in his austin texas home
and he was very buttoned up and then
that that literally
yeah that and that was how he came
across dan i i think
uh
and and i asked him the question
obviously you you mentioned the health
and and the other concerns with baker
and then the other thing is just
you know
does he alienate a portion of the locker
room as some have reported and of course
mort's uh you know report about uh the
adult in the room in cleveland in the
quarterback room and so i said will you
do anything differently in charlotte
than you did in cleveland and he i
thought i thought he gave a pretty good
answer he said look
there is a balance like i i think what i
learned is not to to make everything so
public when things are going poorly or
if there's a an issue with a teammate
he said but i also
you know i can't change who i am i i
have to bring the swagger
or or i'm not going to be the guy the
quarterback i need to be
you know these things always get more
attention
and get heightened when a team's not
winning like cleveland last year
and so i think that'll be the case i
mean are the panthers going to win
uh and then maybe folks are
overlooking or able to sweep some of
that under the rug or maybe baker
changes we'll see like when cam newton
came back last year dan he said he was a
more mature a more humble guy from what
he had gone through in new england
having to wait and take a a prove it
type contract we'll we'll see if the
same
can be true at baker mayfield what about
christian mccaffrey
well he looks good i mean well he always
looks good but
those are usually poses with his shirt
off with his girlfriend in some
far away exotic island
yeah i know
no doubt about it um
he
[Music]
listen there
he had an interesting phone call this
season where he he he
proactively called marshall fog and if
you look at marshall's numbers
around year five year six
marshall went to three straight pro
bowls i think an all-pro three straight
years had some of his most productive
seasons and he called him two because as
you know he's a very similar player
catching the ball out of the back field
lining up in the slot occasionally and
running the ball
and i caught up with falk and shar he
was in charlotte for a speaking
appearance a couple weeks ago and i said
what'd you tell christian because
christian didn't want to get too into it
and he said you know it just comes a
time where you have to train a little
differently you have to practice a
little differently if they're trying to
give you the day off take it don't be
you know don't feel like you have to be
the the you know
it's okay even as a team leader like oh
you're giving me the this wednesday off
take it and then fox said too and and
this dovetails a little bit with what
you were talking about mccaffrey with
his shirt off
is marshall said when he was playing
he takes his shirt off people
weren't sure if he was a professional
athlete
but but he trained he was he was more
into
yoga pilates that kind of thing
rather than bulking up and i think he
shared a lot of that with christian
mccaffrey well
if uh if christian is going to follow
marshall falk's path for success he
should join the rams just like marshall
did where he was with the best offense
in football that certainly helped he's
in carolina and uh
they're gonna ask him to do a whole a
whole lot and i i just i wouldn't have
signed him to the contract extension
never a running back i don't want you
for another contract but
uh if they can use him in a different
way uh you know but but if i'm baker
mayfield i'm like hey christian can you
help me
can you
can you help me get a new contract here
uh so i i don't know if he's able to
change
the role that he's going to play on that
team because it feels like the role that
christian mccaffrey is going to play is
even larger now than uh than it was
before
that became a talking point uh kind of
during the off season i mean it's been a
talking point for two years but it
popped up again
ota's mini camp and matt rule because
there was some talk
will christian play more in the slot
christian mccaffrey and rules said
unequivocally yeah we might do that some
he said but he's a running back and and
he's one of the the best in the game
when healthy
and you're right i mean
last year they did not play him at all
during the pre-season
and then he he's not going to play this
summer either at least in the three
exhibitions
where they ran here's where i think it
started to go
bad for christian last year as they had
two home games both of which they won
uh the second of which was new orleans
he got like 28 touches as he had
in week one
and
four days later he's on the field at
houston on a third in a thursday night
game and and pops his hamstring and i
just think that
he kind of went from zero to 60 having
not had any game action in the preseason
so they got to figure something out
because you're right i mean
baker mayfield or sam darnold or any
quarterback you want to pop in there
has to have mccaffrey for the majority
of the games for this offense to be
successful
well joe carolina got interesting i
don't know if you got any better but you
certainly got more interesting so uh
always great to talk to you and uh thank
you
all right dan have a good summer thank
you joe that's joe person carolina
panthers beat writer for the athletic